becoming a content creator is no easy
task you need to have the knowledge the
looks the personality and the confidence
you also need a great voice and behind
every great voice is a powerful
microphone to get things going enter the
Sennheiser profile USB microphone it is
an affordable all-around microphone that
comes in two flavors one with a stand
for 199 SGD and the other which we have
right now a boom arm set for 309 SGD
assemble it plug it in and you're good
for Zoom Discord and Google meets calls
and streaming with great quality audio
you can hear right now Simplicity that's
the Sennheiser profile USB microphone I
kind of wish they weren't so literal the
name so I'm just going to be calling it
the profile from here on out this isn't
any regular microphone to begin with
it's a cardioid pre-polarized condenser
side address microphone what's a cardio
mic they capture audio mostly from the
front here not So Much from the side and
definitely not the back if you want to
get the best out of your microphone you
gotta stay in front of it and keep it
right in front of you just a quick
comparison this is the rode Wireless go
to Max that we pair out with the road
level 2 microphones we usually run the
setup for most of our videos and if you
don't know how we sound like in those
videos this is how we sound like or how
I sound like with this road set up here
and now we're back to the Sennheiser
profile so let's take a look inside the
Box you get the Sennheiser profile
microphone a three meter long USBC to
USBC cable for it the boom mom and
that's all you need bam bam boom click
whatever sound it makes when you push
the Y into the cable management Gap
thingies because the boom arm does have
it on the side and you're set you don't
need to do anything else that's it it's
that you're done like what else do I
need to say just remember it's a USBC to
USBC cable that's provided Inside the
Box however I did try it out with the
USB 8 USBC cable and it pretty much
works the same I saw the USB 8 USB C
cable over here it's pretty short but it
works so if you're ever in the pinch you
guys can just pick up any kind of cable
you want and just kind of roll with it
of course it's better to use the one
that's provided but this is a viable
option as well so you can move the Blue
Mountain quite a bit you you have about
three points of articulation you have
one like down here if one in the middle
and after that one more right here where
the mic is and of course you can spin it
around if you want you can do that it
takes a bit of force to move the bits
around but that's a good thing because
there is a good amount of tension in all
the joints down here so you won't be
expecting it to be moving around freely
or coming loose anytime soon they really
have to build quality down for this so
don't expect anything less now for the
main mic it has three knobs or gain mix
and monitoring volume a mute button a
port for the USBC cable at the back and
a 3.5 millimeter Jack to put in your
headphones for monitoring like what I'm
doing right now Sennheiser is also sent
us a pair of HD 300 Pro over ear
monitoring headphones and a pair of IE
100 pro iems for us to use you know what
I'm going to change out the HD 300S for
the IES so the HD 300 pros and the ie100
pros have been doing nothing but
enhancing my audio experience from start
to finish or making this video but if
it's listening to music while I'm
writing or even just monitoring the
audio right now it has been a blast so
thank you Sennheiser it's got enough for
adjusting the gain of the mic I usually
start from the 10 o'clock position and
just adjust from there you can get real
soft or real loud and just try it out it
gets pretty loud it gets really loud
besides hearing how loud you are the
ring light around the knob changes color
from green to yellow and yellow
indicates that you're clipping so that's
a nice touch the next knob is for
adjusting the mix between your
microphone and the computer such Mac
you're using so obviously some people
like a mix between the both of them
which I do actually so I can hear what's
happening on the outside when I'm
monitoring my audio when I'm recording
stuff and when I'm listening to say
other things online and also once you're
done with the microphone you can just
shift the mix to the computer side of
the knob and just stay ejected the mute
button there's more to this than meets
the eye not only is it a soft button so
you don't have to hear the huge click
when you're muting your microphone like
other microphones do but it transitions
C industry like
so when you hit unmute it transitions
seamlessly from mute to unmute and vice
versa there's probably a transition
thingy going on probably delaying or
quite simply it cuts the signal cleanly
so when I hit the mute button again as
I'm talking
and then when I hit back to unmute
it's damn smooth moving on the sound
quality it's crisp it's clean and it's
well balanced as expected from the
creative legendary mics such as the e835
or even Hayley Williams or Paramore's
MMD 935-1 it's Sennheiser if anyone
knows a thing or two about sound it's
definitely them because they have 77
years and counting of other experience
so they have your pack the profiles
capsule inside here does the job well
and more with pretty good noise
rejection moving the boom around you
can't really hear the adjustment noises
being made by the RMS or maticulating
the middle section or even the bit where
it holds the microphone but of course if
you're hitting the microphone like this
you know you're obviously going to hear
things but for the most part when you're
adjusting the boom arm it doesn't pick
up anything else you can't really hear
the adjustment sounds being made like me
you know just adjusting knobs over here
especially the mute button because you
know it's a soft button so
you could slap a windshield on this but
it handles pulses pretty well pit bag
bat cat
a great mind needs to work well with
good hardware and if you're looking for
a new laptop to pair with this
microphone here's a message from our
friends at Aces this video is brought to
you by Asus check out the Asus Zenbook
14x OLED Space Edition commemorating the
25th anniversary of the first Asus
laptop sent into space Not only does it
offer a space exclusive design but it's
even worthy of going where no man has
gone before with its space gray
durability it even comes with a 3.5 inch
OLED companion Zen Vision display and
you will have a ball of a time taking
interviews with a 16x10 4K OLED Nano
Edge Pantone validated 14 inch display
the Sennheiser profile doesn't need any
kind of companion app for it to function
and we also have the Razer serum V2 Pro
and the Blue Yeti both of which have
companion apps logic G Hub and region
synapse respectively and speaking of
these two mics we're going to be running
through them right now the Razer 7 V2
Pro isn't all right mate you can check
out our review like down here yeah like
right here it does its job but I think
competitors Sennheiser profile mic it's
a no-brainer as to who beats out who
want the audio front however the blue
Stills and highest biggest competitor in
the USB microphone space and yes I did
change it too so it is getting a bit
cold I'll change out after this this
microphone is used by streamers
everywhere and has a great companion app
to boot the yeti is truly among the best
as an all-rounder I've only heard great
things about this microphone especially
from Zaki who used this mic at his desk
I even recorded some lines with the blue
yeti for the RG phone 6 Diablo multi
Edition video that we did you can check
it out down here to see how the quality
is like so let me know how it sounds
like to you thus it has a profile with
the stand and not this boom arm down
here costs about the same as a Blue Yeti
so at the end of the day it just boils
down to how you want your output to
sound like and if you'd like extra
features but the Synology profile is on
par with the yeti as far as my ears can
tell and because they both sound really
good but let's just do a quick
comparison so you guys can note the
differences this is a microphone test
with the Sennheiser profile USB
microphone
this is how it sounds like this is a
microphone test with the razer's hearing
V2 Pro
this is how it sounds like this is a
microphone test with a Blue Yeti this is
how it sounds like alright so with that
little test and with my lines from
before I hope you guys have a better
understanding of where the Sennheiser
profile stands we are also going to be
putting it through different distances
and situations you may find yourselves
in such as calls with apps like Discord
and Google meets and if you're a
streamer we're going to be testing it
with a keyboard you know so you know it
sounds like we're confused gaming and if
you're a Music Streamer we're going to
be playing I'm going to be playing my
guitar so let me know what you think of
the synergic profile USB microphone in
the comment section below at the end of
this test the gain is set to 12 o'clock
and this is how it sounds like when
you're really close and this is how it
sounds like when you're really far away
for the microphone
so yeah there is a huge difference the
this is how the Sennheiser profile USB
microphone sounds like when you are on a
Discord call
this is how it sounds like when you're
engaged in a Google meets call with the
Sennheiser profile USB microphone
all right so this is the streamer
section this is how it sounds like when
you're gaming furiously on your keyboard
let's check out you know the sounds of
the table quick
and also if you guys want to use this
microphone for say ASMR stuff for
keyboards you can hear the talk and
everything this keyboard isn't talking
at all but you guys can hear how it
sounds like
right so this is how it sounds like for
music streamers if you guys want to play
your guitar in it here's some finger
picking real quick
[Music]
right so this is how it sounds like when
you want to strum stuff
[Music]
this last part is how it sounds like
when you're singing and playing your
guitar through a single Sennheiser
microphone
let's talk about the summer
[Music]
and the first time that I saw you
let's search this guy
for a while
you and I
could like to start
for a while
you and I
[Music]
all right
that's it for the tasks after going
through the setup the test and using
this microphone as a daily driver for
quite a bit doesn't Hazard profile USB
microphone proves that great audio
doesn't have to be complicated it's
accessible and it handles noise
rejection pretty well and a good amount
of thought has been put into its design
for its build and the audio the setup is
easy it sounds good and it looks damn
good too I guess the only thing that
Sennheiser falls short off is the lack
of an app like g-hop or resistant apps
some people have voice filters and
having more control over their
microphone's audio so would you want
this enhancer profile to have an app let
us know in the comment section below
because I personally feel that so long
as my mic is reliable and it sounds good
that's all that matters besides that
it's no frills good and clear audio and
I highly recommend that you guys get
this in either set whether it's with the
stand or the boom arm if you guys want
to up your audio game if you have any
questions about the Sennheiser profile
USB microphone let me know in the
comment section down below and I'll do
my best to get to them and don't forget
to follow us on all of our socials right
here to keep up to date with the latest
news that we put out and if you like
this video make sure to like And
subscribe to us it goes a long way also
if you want to see more stuff from us
check this out
[Music]
foreign